ciao says he has sleep paralysis and he
says the cure for sleep paralysis is to
control and release your soul from your
body how do you do that Rob and you
don't know how to do then sound figured
it out I did
he says doing this as a form of quote
astral projection or astral travel yes
Sal says he's flown out of his body into
several different rooms in his house so
Sal you had kind of a superpower when
you suffered from this sleep paralysis
you realize you could leave your body by
taking your soul and flying around your
house it may sound odd but it doesn't
sound out at all it is I guess a good
comparison to a superpower but Howard
the good news is that we all have this
we all have this superpower did you just
fly around your house it's called the
dream yeah that's right why wouldn't you
fly into the cosmos why do you have in
your house I I'm afraid of heights what
time I left the house I in the house
doesn't scare you doesn't scare me but I
did I did indeed I swear to you I did
indeed leave the house and I shot up to
the stars
go ahead I was going very very fast
really fast night and I got closer and
closer to the Stars and I did panic and
then I willed myself did you happen to
pass the Sun no I got close to the Stars
and then it came back with the stars
very hot
no they appeared brighter and brighter
it was almost like being in a
planetarium why didn't you go to the Sun
is because it's too hot well it's
nighttime at night this Sun wasn't there
it was there but it was you know my mood
so whatever in a time you were flying
toward the Sun but it wasn't there
because it was nine times exactly all I
saw was stars hour now it's flying very
fast extremely fast like a like rock
what is the Sun by the way I'm curious
the Sun is the biggest star in the world
the Sun is not the biggest star in the
world it is - Robin no it's not it
appears bigdhaas because it's the
biggest if it's close its big ah no it
doesn't make it big it means it's closer
to you if I put my hand your faces look
big Robin yes
so really big it's big visually will you
ever use your powers to perhaps spy on
other countries and
their secrets like Kim jong-un and will
you ever visit him through Ashley if I
wouldn't know what the hell he's talking
about I don't speak Korean
she will not look that is no point in
that right you would not go to these
other countries you know leave it to
nature to give the superpowers to a guy
who can't use that Sal Sal L from
Krypton sellout
have you ever when you're flying around
in the skies have you ever run into
anyone else who's flying around no I
haven't but you can make arrangements
with other people to do that oh you're
gonna make a date no I
I've stopped doing it why would you stop
doing that wonderful superpower I told
my mother about it and she made me
promise her I won't do it
why boy thinks I'm going to detach my
umbilical my sole ability on bilkul
Court which is called a silver cord if
that severs you could die how did you
learn about the silver cord most of us
don't know about this well the silver
umbilical cord is what keeps you
connected to your physical body when
where did you read that at Carlos
Castaneda where did you read that ah
this very good website called Wikipedia
okay you read away right and they told
you about astral projection we're all
connected to the silver umbilical I told
you I was making a reality show called
the long island [ __ ] would you starring
it's gonna be using so you say your
mother met with you and said I Sal I
want you to aprama Smee
that you will a stop book as for
projecting although very upset why was
your mother I'd smack you in the back of
the head I think why wouldn't you spy on
me you're so obsessed with me why
wouldn't you go because you're so happy
just being free you're in another
dimension it's just so liberating
another dimension you say you're on
earth but you're in a different realm of
Earth you're in a different earth - I
really liked when I floated one time
when Jimmy Kimmel was on television
I saw a Buddha and a giant hand that was
another time I what did this just have
to do with Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel was
on TV good and I was floating so I
wasn't dreaming I was watching Jimmy
Kimmel on television with your astral
projection you sat and watched Jimmy Kim
I floated above my bed and watched Jimmy
Kimmel and then if that's what you did
you watch Jimmy Kimmel well I floated
that's a good show if you would stop you
from floating around the earth I floated
up
Jimmy Kimmel was on and he was I
remember seeing his show live right and
to the right of Jimmy Kimmel was a
beautiful gold Buddha with all these
jewels and to the right of that Buddha
was a giant hand a giant giant ham with
really long fingers and it was reaching
out to me and I was floating in my bed
up above my bed and I said to the hand
I'm not afraid of you I'm not afraid of
you and Jimmy Kimmel was doing his jokes
and I looked at the Buddha and then I
stopped myself and I went wow you're so
mental it's funny no I'm [ __ ] mental
you know what I think he's so miserable
and realized he's creating the fantasy
world like a child you've had a complete
break with reality no I [ __ ] thing I
ever heard I just let you talk and I
can't even I go I can't believe I hired
this [ __ ]
and now I'm going to ask you one last
favor and I mean this yes would you
project yourself out of here all right
thank you
ed in the sand flying out right now I
see him
you